kid where are you mr. stork madam out
there devastated where are the snacks
I'm getting them right now man is there
anyone Wow your DJ get ready
you're spider-man what are you doing
here I'm going to this finals party
starts party I'm going to look can we
get a picture to look welcoming thank
you
Wow me yes we are first another one I
love it
another I gotta go my skin give it
finally here we go good evening here
cold
you have 576 possible ocean elimination
- ha ha
I can keep that - yeah son for me was
really retreat look next mission will
call you alright
it's not a hug time just grab the tough
way all right there yet
all right kids good luck out there big
eater you going tonight I can't tonight
I got the astark internship what's up
guys here's my report for tonight I
stopped the Grandstaff bicycle hey could
you do me a favor hold on by I help this
old lady and she bought me a churro so I
was nice I just feel like I could be
doing more wait a minute you guys on the
real event just hope gives it away you
move them working on the bed
he's working for crazy dangerous missin
tater there people who handle this sort
of thing can't you just be a friendly
neighborhood spider-man
actually the world to change in boys
timely change to my can't prove myself
you Spanish Queen
you gotta get better at this part of the
job oh I'm dated
where you going what are you hiding
Peter I'm just getting out here by
there's a ton of other social systems in
here but we're all disabled by the
training wheels protocols because mister
start treating me like a kid could you
are a kid yeah you can stop a boss with
his bare hands
you